the jurogan experience shelley duvall oh
shelley duvall yeah
and she had trauma from it to this day
she talks about the trauma she had in
that movie i was reading a story with an
interview with her like she kind of
vanished
yeah and then they were interviewing her
and she sounded insane
yeah i think it pushed her over the edge
i think that movie [ __ ] people up
cubic was a strange guy yeah do you know
he would do complex mathematics in his
spare time
really yeah he's like a legitimate
genius wow
and he would put all sorts of like weird
hidden meaning
into all of his movies like a thing was
never just a thing
like a there's there's a big crazy
conspiracy about the shining that inside
of it
is all sorts of uh information
that uh is it relates to the moon land
yeah
yeah like yeah the room in the hotel
it was room 127 and the moon is 127
000 miles from the earth or something no
it's it's like 237 two weeks whatever it
was the moon is yeah the moon is like
200 i think i think it's room 237 right
yeah 237.
that's the documentary on it the the
moon is
well it depends on what time of the year
and where but it's
between 237 and 265 000 miles away
well and they say that he directed the
the fake movie
about the fake moon landing well that's
the that's the big conspiracy theory
what is the thing in the
the circle with the jack nicholson
picture there
oh there's uh the coffee what does it
say it's the coffee it might be the
coffee
calumet what does that mean what is
calumet
and then the other one you go up scroll
up you see the circles there's rockets
on the wall uh-huh sort of sort of that
is that is whatever that is
yeah strange yeah there's but he was
into weird [ __ ]
he was a i mean he was a legitimate
genius yeah like
eyes wide shut that's another [ __ ]
strange movie he had a lot of strange
movies man
yeah he did what did he do clockwork
orange was that him yeah
that was cuba full metal jacket
documentary that whole thing they shot
in london
because he didn't want he wouldn't leave
his home really so they made uh
like the second half of the movie
supposed to be in vietnam or like some
area in part of england really yeah
wow he wouldn't leave london [ __ ] you
i'm staying here
but but this movie's supposed to be in
the middle of the jungle
yeah well it's right here here's the
jungle [ __ ] off right
damn he did some wild ass [ __ ] movies
yeah man
he did 2001 the the i the this
conspiracy theory about him directing
the moon landing was that he was doing
it
at the same time he was doing 2001 so
because he was faking
this space movie 2001 a space odyssey
that they used him to fake the moon
landing footage
and there's a fake documentary not a
real documentary but a fake
like a mockumentary where he's admitting
and people are talking about have you
seen that one no but that makes sense
yeah a lot of people like dude you
didn't even know there's an actual
real interview with him where he admits
that he faked the moon landing uh
but it's not yeah it's just it's fake
but it's were you ever on the uh
in the camp of the moon landing was fake
for years yeah yeah
it's one of my favorite all-time
conspiracies because it's so strange
that we never went back
i abandoned it because i don't know
anything about
astrophysics or space travel or any of
that stuff
and the people that do think it's real
so i'm like okay
well most likely they think the landing
really happened
yeah but there's so many weird things to
it there's so many there's so many weird
things with the photographs
and there's like intersecting shadows
that indicate different light sources
there's all sorts of
flag waving that's weird [ __ ] man
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] the fact
that uh the this is the only time in
human history
that something is not cheaper easier and
faster to replicate
than it was in 1969. between 1969 1972
there was seven trips six successful
when they went to the moon and back
and uh every every space flight since
then has been like near earth orbit
you know everything is like you know
just a few miles up
it's not they don't they don't go like
they did that i mean i think everything
since then it's like 300 miles
every human travel you know like space
shuttles and stuff like that
they never go that far yeah they never
go into deep space and come back the
only time they came back was during the
moon landings in the 60s
when they were lying about everything
yeah the thing is like nixon was
president back then it was like
it's so romantic cambodian yeah
it's so romantic to think that they
faked it also here's another reason
if you watch the post flight press
conference
and again i'm not saying that this is
what's this is actually what's happening
but it
seems completely like they're full of
[ __ ]
when they come back it seems like
they're lying and they're nervous and
they ask them about the stars and and
again
i'm not on the camp that they faked it
but uh there was uh you know buzz aldrin
neil armstrong and um michael collins
and michael collins they asked him about
stars
and in the press conference he's like uh
i don't recall seeing any stars
problem with that is like michael
collins never left the lunar module
he wasn't supposed to be one of the guys
that was on the surface of the moon
he was up in the the craft that was
circling you know those
in orbit around the moon and then later
when he wrote a book about it he talked
about how magnificent the stars looked
so he has inconsistencies so the the
hoax people
point to that they also point to the
inconsistencies
of the uh the actual movement of the
astronauts on the moon
like uh there's videos that make it look
like they were on wires
there's videos that yeah there's like
the back of this suit is being pulled by
something it's weird but again like when
was the last time you saw someone in one
sixth earth gravity maybe that's just
maybe things just look weird
but there's a video of them where it
looks like they're on trampolines which
is very strange
they're bouncing around on the surface
the moon like literally and you can't
see their feet or they're like hidden
behind equipment they're just bouncing
up in the air and
it's fun it's fun to think that kubrick
faked it all
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience